new at six a story of perseverance and
an unwavering Bond a teen and his mom
faced with a difficult diagnosis and a
tough decision good
good awareness
teammates friends mother and son the
bond these two share is unique and
certainly something many adults might
find challenging but for the Lopez's
it's their strength together that gives
them motivation to move forward I always
like to look at it as half full
heartening words from a 14 year old who
just like other teens has braces loves
video games and has high aspirations for
his future I see myself working as a
forensic pathologist but Tyler Lopez is
more than just her average teen he's
also the sole caregiver to his mom
Allison from day one she is such a
strong
Brave woman she's absolutely incredible
Alison has multiple sclerosis I was told
that within six months I would just need
to accept that I would be in a
wheelchair drooling somewhere and I
wasn't willing to accept that as a
diagnosis she says she ignored early
signs for years like Vision disturbances
and limb weakness the product of being a
busy working mom and caring for others
as a flight medic to have those roles
reversed and have to ask for help is a
very humbling experience she says it was
a gradual process of change but one that
forced some complex decisions most
children don't have to make we just had
to have some really honest and in-depth
conversations about where we were what
he was willing to shoulder as a
responsibility and what I was willing to
allow him to shoulder because he still
has he still needs to be a kid Tyler is
the youngest primary caregiver to any of
my patients he has maturity level that
goes well beyond his years Dr Carrie
Hirsch is the program director for
health and wellness at the Cleveland
Clinic Lou rouvo Center for brain health
Allison and Tyler traveled to the center
from their home outside Albuquerque for
its comprehensive MS program the overall
goal of our treatment is to slow down
the progression of the disease while
also making sure that we are paying
particular attention to their safety
their quality of life and their function
at home from disease modifying therapies
to educational programs and support
groups Allison says it's been pivotal in
her development so physically I am so
much better than I thought I'd ever be
but the Lou rouvo Center also provides
for caregivers the Cleveland Clinic has
really has really treated me like family
and they've really taken me in taking
care of my own mental health before I
can take care of her an unshakable bond
between this mother and son teen I never
knew it was possible to love somebody
any more than I already did rooting for
each other come on you can do it just
one more step I asked Allison where she
sees herself in five or ten years and
she said happy healthy and spreading
awareness and that's their big goal to
help others get diagnosed early so they
can begin treatment right away and to
celebrate and of course recognize all
the caregivers like Tyler Heather Mills
eight news now